hi conan o'brien here again on google
plus this is my second week very excited
last week i featured judgmental animals
uh got a lot of blow back
uh
from that little stunt turns out
judgmental animals have judgmental
owners
who are also litigious so my lawyers are
well they're working through that one i
apologize to everyone especially uh the
peevish cobra owner sorry about that
um anyway we're gonna try something else
this second week that i'm on google plus
very excited about this
it's called round the world with conan
here's what i'm gonna do i'm going to
spin
this globe
every day
randomly pick out a different location
and then go to that location in 24 hours
and return then do it again the next day
no one has ever attempted anything like
this in the history of the internet or
any medium
for that fact
and bang here we go
mongolia
i'm not gonna do this
it's a long way
i
no
forget it
just enjoy google plus
have a good time
not going up
mongolia
google plus
why is my globe red